I know that even in the United States
when you have someone like Donald Trump
I know that there is a lot of elitist
liberal reaction like here we see the
limit of democracy but in the wrong case
in the sense that you see stupid
ordinary people are seduced and so on
and so on well although Nam Tomsky
doesn't like me very much
I I admire him sincerely and I must
admit that I like his term I think it's
not just journalistic term it's a
concept which he took over from American
tradition even mainstream right wing
liberal of manufacturing concern you
know democracy is not only formal rules
of Elections democracy is an entire
thick network of how political consensus
is built a lot of unwritten rules and
now I think United States are at a very
important moment at the moment when this
machine to to to build consensus it has
broken down now these are moment which
can be catastrophic in such moments
direct fascism can take over but this
can be also moments when the left or
whatever would be the new left provides
a new answer so my first reaction to
those elytis liberals who claim you see
the stupid red redneck white trash or
whatever are voting for Trump is yes but
if your responsibility one moment of
truth in all those enraged people who
vote for Trump is that they nonetheless
so clearly that this traditional machine
of manufacturing consent no longer works
to put it in this slightly bombastic and
exaggerated Marxist terms the ruling
ideology uses mobilizes certain
machinery to keep people at track to
control the excesses and so on that
machinery no longer works and here I'm
not just the pessimist in contrast to
liberals for whom Trump is the ultimate
devil ooh it's a nightmare and so on I
claim no no it's much more complex of
course Trump is almost but not quite
proto-fascist phenomenon but it's
because they the liberal centrist
mainstream because they failed and
that's why not that I like in any way
Trump Trump is scum trash and so on but
my butt is earth is this one first
Trump nonetheless if you are leftist you
should admire him sincerely he did
something wonderful he almost
single-handedly destroyed the Republican
Party that what I mean you have two main
vaguely orientations the Christian
fundamentalist in the party hardliners
in this Republican liberal enlightened
big business elite both of them are more
or less horrified of Trump and Trump is
vulgar but in his very vulgarity you can
see a common human business opportunism
now I will say something horrible but
for me people like Ted Cruz or you
remember eight years ago Rick Santorum
there's something much worse Trump is a
dirty disgusting human being do you
really think that Rick Santorum is a
human being I think that they are aliens
there is something so monstrous about
them so that might add from my second
point is that I never trusted this
absolute obsession with Trump oh now we
should be all together just to stop
Trump for this
we sacrificed Bernie Sanders this is how
Hillary got us Hillary is not just LGBT
rights a little bit more progressive
Hillary's today the vote of the
establishment even of the cultural
establishment a free do you know that
most of the big names of of neocons from
the era of George Bush Paul Wolfowitz
and so on they moved to Hillary now
Hillary is not only the voice of the
liberal establishment
he's also the voice of let's call it
cold war establishment now in the last
days there was a propaganda against a
Trump saying oh but can we trust this
guy he will bring us into a new world
war know I'm much more afraid that
Hillary will do this so again in no way
I am for Trump he's he personifies what
I was talking about this disintegration
of public values of public learners this
obscene situation where you can talk
about whatever you want again think
which years ago were unthinkable as part
of a public debate are now normalized
open racism and so on and here I think
political correctness doesn't work
because political correctness is a
desperate attempt when public mores all
these unwritten rules which tell you
what is this and what is not break down
political correctness tries directly to
legislate this expression is to be used
that expression is to be used and so on
and so on what makes me afraid of this
procedure is the following do you
remember how two years ago or even three
four sorry when all this debate about
torture begins boarding waterboarding
and so on US Army did something very
nice they no longer talked about torture
but about I think the term was enhanced
interrogation technique and this is for
me
establishment version
of political correctness you know you
put a nicer name like I can well imagine
the 10 years from now and it's not a
joke
I claim rape will be called well why not
enhanced seduction technique you know
like this basic politically correct idea
that you use words which will not hurt
the addressee
I totally subscribe to this when we are
dealing with all these marginal sexual
identities which can traumatize you and
so on but I absolutely don't think that
this is any kind of universal right not
to be called in a way which hurt you
let's take a big criminal corporation
boss who maybe also want to see him as a
humanitarian no he should be publicly
called with words which will hurt him
and that's the whole point that he
should be hurt and so on and so on so
again I I don't like this narcissistic
idea of you know the ultimate crisis do
you feel hurt are you wounded or not and
so on and so on I mean this is a very
ambiguous topic of course you can in
this way defend gay rights the exclusion
of LGBT people and so on but then what
would prevent what would prevent white
Aryans or whatever white power people to
say sorry guys but we are hurt if you
attack us like this and so on no in
politics we have authentic enemies
everyone should not be respected in
politics and so on
politics is a real struggle of life and
death
you
[Music]